but those words that we were hearing um
from the russian security council this
morning about the possibility of the
russians at bringing in troops bringing
in volunteers from the middle east is
that a little bit of posturing by the
russians or do you think there might be
some truth to that
the russians have been giving us
non-stop propaganda i would doubt
anything that they told us that was true
they denied that they were using
conscripts on the front line in ukraine
we now know that they were
they told us that we're making great
progress we know that they've taken
heavy losses uh they said that they
would be welcomed in ukraine as
liberators we know that they've had
heavy resistance from the ukrainians i'm
i'm here in warsaw in poland and we've
been talking to some of the people doing
the humanitarian runs into ukraine and
they've been telling us about the
appalling state of some of the cities
there people with no food and no water
who are being purposely starved by the
russians that this is an act of cruel
aggression with no respect whatsoever
for human life we saw yesterday the
bombing of a maternity hospital in a
children's hospital and these are almost
certainly war crimes and i wouldn't
believe a word that came from the
russian propagandists
and and as we're speaking at dr fox news
reaching me via the reuters wire service
at the russian forces have hit a
psychiatric hospital
in ukraine's heart cave region that
according uh to the haki regional
governor i mean looking at the tactics
that we have seen the russians deploying
so far when you hear the white house
when you hear downing street talking
about the potential use of of chemical
and biological weapons indeed you're
hearing vladimir putin talking about it
it all starts to look very very
concerning indeed
well the whole thing is already very
concerning um remember that this is a
humanitarian crisis brought about by
choice it's brought about by choice by
putin against ukraine a country that
didn't uh threaten russia in any way he
talks about them being one people and
yet he's willing to inflict an appalling
level of death and suffering on men
women and children so the fact that he
might escalate it by using chemical
weapons actually wouldn't really
surprise me although it would appall me
to the core
absolutely appalling but when you have
an individual like vladimir putin in
charge of russia who as you say has been
shown to have used chemical weapons even
even in the united kingdom of course in
the past
how then is it possible that that
keeping our nerves as you're going to
see in the speech later on today and
using our economic might is the way to
is the way to ultimately win this
conflict
well we've got two choices one is we can
enter the military conflict
and cause a major escalation and
possibly a war across all of europe or
we can use the most effective tools we
have which are to [ __ ] the russian
economy uh putin needs uh his war
machine to be fed we can stop it being
fed by reducing the amount of money that
it has access to the the sanctions on
the russian central bank i'm not sure
that people understand exactly how
severe those are they will actually stop
russia getting access to the money that
is put aside putin's war machine being
funded by foreign currency reserves that
he's got in banks around the world he
now doesn't have access to those
about 600
billion dollars suddenly is not
available to the the kremlin and that
makes a big difference because he's
unable to support the value of his
currency at home he's unable to maintain
banking stability in russia which means
as the possibility of both runs on banks
themselves and the possibility of
hyperinflation in russia now as you
correctly say when you've got a
sociopath like putin in charge you may
not care what happens to the ordinary
russian people
but they may here what happens to them
and that therefore threatens the
stability of the regime and of course
the best thing to happen is that
vladimir putin himself is not there
certainly is
in your mind do you think that vladimir
excuse me do you think that vladimir
putin will ultimately face charges at
the international criminal court
well he could face charges whether he
actually faces the courts another matter
uh people like putin have a
a way of avoiding justice but it's very
clear that if war crimes have been
created then it looks as though we're
seeing indiscriminate shelling of
civilian targets in hospitals a
psychiatric hospital as you say this
morning and these are grotesque crimes
and for what what does putin hope to
gain from this he can't occupy ukraine
he doesn't have the troops to do it
clearly the ukrainians don't want him to
be there ultimately it seems that a very
high price will be paid for the fact
that vladimir putin lives in his own
bizarre world with uh very few advisers
willing to tell him the truth about the
the world outside uh and living with his
own fantasies and demons it's it's a
very depressing picture
but the best tools that we have are to
to deal with the money that with which
he finances the war and the russian
economy which props up his regime